这是Al Brooks,这是我经济的经济费用程式
这个模式是关于经济设计的
市场是控制经济设计的
你只能做钱,如果你经济在这一方
经济设计的方式,如果市场的经济设计
如果市场的经济设计是控制的
你只能做钱,如果你经济设计
如果市场设计在控制的方式,你必须在市场上看
设计方式的经济设计
任何想法,你能想象的
是一个设计方式
即使市场在一个非常厉害的设计中
你会有很高的设计方式
用来刮花,用来刮花
如果市场设计在一个非常厉害的设计中
你会有很高的设计方式
每次市场在市场下方的中央
你会有更高的设计方式
在某个时候,它将回到中央
它将打到中央
它将打到 its first entry
然后将打到2nd and 3rd entries
它将往上个中央
它将往上一个,然后将往下
它将回到中央
至它的第一点的设计
它将跌出在某个中央
即使是在某个期待的设计中
它将跌出在某个期待的设计中
objective
plus
b聛
ę
我
Bullish programs are trying to create upside breakouts and bearish programs are adding to positions trying to create downside breakouts.
Eventually one side wins and the other side covers.
So for example, if the bulls are successful in creating a very big bull breakout,
the bears who are shorting in the trading range will buy back their shorts.
That adds to the buying and adds to the breakout and those bears will not be eager to short again.
So you'll have bears sitting on the sidelines not shorting and that means the market has to go higher to find a price where they'll be willing to short again.
So during breakouts the market can become very one sided.
Now the markets are controlled by programs and they cannot hide what they're doing.
The price action shows everyone exactly what's going on.
So if the market is going up bar after bar after bar,you know the buy programs are winning and the sell programs are losing.
And if you know that the buy programs are in control,then you have to get long or look for ways to get long.
You know they cannot be stealthy about it.It's not like,you know,50 firms are out there buying and the market is going up and they're doing it in a secret way.
They're showing us what they're doing.If the market is going up,we know that there are more dollars going into buy programs than into sell programs.
And that we should look to buy.
You know,you cannot move the market.
You know,traders always think,oh my gosh,if I buy here,it'll make the market pop up.
Or if I sell here,it'll make the market pop down.
Or if I'm long and I put a stop below that bar,the market's going to see my stop and it's going to come down and get my stop.
That is absolutely not true.
You know,the market cannot get to any price above or below where the market currently is unless one or more institutions wants to buy or sell at that price.
Remember,the market,to be at any price,there has to be a buyer and a seller.
So there have to be institutions wanting to sell there.It's not you or your friends wanting to sell on a stop below the low of the current bar or above or buy above a prior seller.
You cannot make the market get above that high.It only gets above that high.
If there is one or more institutions who want to buy above that high.
So,you know,the market totally ignores anything that you do.
And you can say,well,I saw a breakout the other day in the E-mini and only three contracts traded.That's right.
Sometimes that happens.Sometimes an institution will move the market with a three-lot order.
But,you know,you try to move it on a three-lot order.You will not be able to do it.
So if the market goes above a certain price and only three contracts are trading,you have to assume it did that because an institution did it.
Not because somebody at home did it.
And probably there's a reason for that institution doing it.
The institution may have wanted the market to go down and may have wanted to trigger traders into thinking that it was going up.
And then as soon as they bought their three contracts,a tick down,maybe a tick,they then sold 200.
So if you want to sell at any price,whether to get short or to get stopped out of a bad trade,the market cannot reach your price unless there are institutions that are selling at a low price.
There are institutions who want to sell at that same price.You know,the market's not going to go to your price no matter how big a position you have.
The market's not going to go to your price because of you.It will only get to that price if institutions want to sell at that same price.
High-frequency trading firms,HFTs,have received a lot of publicity lately.They were on 60 minutes about a year ago.
And all a high-frequency trading firm is a type of a program trading firm.They create most of the day's volume.
And some of the big markets,they can create 50%,maybe even 75% of the volume of trading.
And the firms trade a scalp for tiny profits.What's a tiny profit?Sometimes a penny,sometimes less than a penny.
And they'll be trading a huge number of trades.Ultimately,they don't have any significant effect on the direction of the market.
You know,they're just looking for a penny up,a penny down,two pennies up,two pennies down.And they really don't have any significant effect on where the market is going.
A typical firm might trade 10 to 50 million trades a day.And the trades are small.They're only 100 contracts,100 shares in a stock,300 shares.
But if you take 50 million shares and you're trying to make one penny and you write 55% of the time,you can end up having a pretty good day.
Okay,they create 70% of the volume in most of the major markets.Other institutions create 25% of the volume.
And you and I,on a good day,might make up 5% of the volume.The high-frequency trading firms are really concerned about latency.
Latency is the time from when a trade takes place to the time that they see the trade on their computer.
And they rent very expensive space very close to the exchanges.And they have very fast computers to try to knock off milliseconds in the latency.
They often hold their trades for fractions of a second,sometimes to hours,but for the most part for a very short period of time.And they're looking for a very small profit.
I will talk about extreme scalping in one of the later modules.And that is a manual version of high-frequency trading.
So for example,the e-mini has 81 bars during the trading day.And on a typical day there are about 40 possible scalps.
So if you're a scalper looking for all of those one-point scalps during the day,you are basically a high-frequency trader.
But instead of doing it using computers,you're doing it manually.
Going back to what I was saying,institutions make up 95% of the trading.They're not out to get your money.You don't have enough money to interest them.
Remember,95% of the dollars out there are from institutions.That 95% is not looking at the 5% as their source of income.
Each one of the firms in that 95% are looking at the other firms in that 95% as the source of their income.
So none of the firms cares about,Skullman Sachs is not trying to take money from you.They're trying to take money from Citibank,from JP Morgan,from Credit Suisse,from Morgan Stanley,from all of the hedge funds.
That's where all the money is.And that's where they're trying to get their money.
Although a lot of times when you're starting out,it feels like they're trying to screw the little guy.They don't care that you exist.You don't have enough money.
All the little guys put together do not have enough money to interest the institutions.So the institutions are never out to get you.
High frequency trading firms,how much profit potential do they have?
For example,let's look at a firm that makes 10 million trades a day.
And each trade is for,let's say 100 shares.And they win 55% of the time.
So they make a penny on 5.5 million trades.And they lose a penny on 4.5 million trades.
Let's just use that as our hypothetical.
Then they end up with 5.5 million winning pennies,which is $5.5 million.
And they have 4.5 million losing pennies,or $4.5 million.
So their net profit today,a million dollars.
Net profit per year,there are about 200 plus trading days a year.
That's $200 million for the year.
The high frequency trading firms are just like you and me.They're out to chase riches.
And they know that there's a huge profit potential.And that huge profit potential results in the formation of lots of firms chasing that profit.
But there's a fallacy.Everyone thinks that all the high frequency trading firms are making a lot of money.
And that's not the reality.Many of them lose money.And only the very best firms do as well as an example that I just gave.
The high frequency trading firms receive a lot of press.And the media makes it sound like if you're not making money,it's because of the high frequency trading firms.
The reason you're not making money is not that the high frequency trading firms are the problem.
It's because you're the problem.Everyone wants to blame everyone else for their losses.
But if you lose,it's because you're not yet good enough.Everyone knows that the dollars are there.That's why all of us are here.
We all want some of the dollars.We all want a lot of the dollars.But you're competing against very good people.
Pretty much a level playing field.And you have to learn how to trade if you're expecting to take dollars from other very good traders.
This is the end of the module on program trading.